so good to see you both uh
congratulations on this tremendous film
uh it was such a big deal Leticia you
guys brought Rihanna back
like that's amazing how do you feel
about that
um it's beautiful it's wonderful that
she saw meaning and purpose and she
wanted to make
um a song that on a chat in his family
and and for her to do that and be a part
of this journey with us is incredible
you know
um
I'm so excited for our audience members
to hear these beautiful songs that she
has
um performed and and graced us with her
with her presence to be a part of of
this film so excited for everyone to
hear it
yeah now I want all the viewers of this
film to go on the same emotional Journey
that I went on with the twists and turns
and surprises so no spoilers here at all
but I you know shuri of course has been
a fan favorite for a long time how
excited have you been for audience to
see her evolution in this film
man it's been really cool to just study
shuri from the comic books and like you
know from the moment I booked the part
I was so intrigued by by her Arc and I
really loved that and I love the fact
that we get to tap into to that
on on this one and I love the fact that
you know as we we dive into her world we
dive into
um the world of one of the
the the oldest Marvel characters
um ever which is Neymar and and to Notch
plays in brilliantly and and to see that
Dynamic and that connection
is really cool
um yeah
tonight whenever you and Leticia are on
screen together it's electric like it
really is phenomenal
um do you yourself see Namor as a hero
because I think he sees himself as a
hero yeah totally and I think a lot of
people uh
all around the world I'm gonna see
Neymar like a hero he is protecting his
people he's doing well the he's going as
far as he has to go to protect his
people to protect his culture to protect
his uh
City and everything that he loved the
most
and I mean everybody
in the world every human being is doing
basically the same thing all the time so
I think that people are gonna connect
with that aspect of their character
now I mean these two characters they
share the same wound they share uh the
same grief but what different for
different reasons and they take
different paths to solve and to heal you
know so
but but the beauty thing of this is both
of them
they have an explanation why they choose
each path you know Neymar is is 500
years old or more you know so he went
through different options to deal with
the grief to deal with the anger and
finally he said okay there is just one
way there is just one path and he take
that you know he follows his uh yeah he
this this this uh Road and uh and for
sure it's different but you know there
is a strong identification on both of
them it's like like parallels parallel
Journeys you know what I mean
yeah well guys again I'm excited for
everyone to see this you did a
phenomenal job both you congratulations
thank you thank you buddy